[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
Ladies and gentlemen,
the program
will begin in three minutes.
Please switch your phone to
silent and take your seat.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
Ladies and gentlemen,
the program is beginning.
Please be seated.
[TECHNO MUSIC]
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
Ladies and gentlemen, please
welcome to the stage, President
of Sales and Operations, Google
Great China, Scott Beaumont.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SCOTT BEAUMONT:
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
OK, time to change channel.
It's great to see you all here.
And as I said, one of
the things that I really
love doing when I'm in China
is traveling the country.
You really get to see the signs
of progress, the innovation,
and the pace of change.
And actually, the
developer community,
you're here in the room
and the live stream.
This is what you represent.
And today is actually
part the day's
to celebrate your achievements
and to congratulate all of you,
and to give you the
opportunity to mix together.
It's also an opportunity
to talk to you
about how Google can help
you develop your ideas
and can help you go global.
And we're going to
explore that a great deal
over the course of today
and the breakout sessions.
For those of you who
work with us already,
hopefully we inspire you
to even greater heights,
and for those of you
who don't know us yet,
today should be a good day.
OK, first off, let's
talk a little bit
about something you
all know very well,
which is digital China.
It's said that every
seven minutes in China,
a new business is created,
and 50% of those businesses
are digital only.
We live in a market where over
half the population is online,
and 92% are using the web
through their mobile devices.
And actually the great
majority of those
are using the web only
via their mobile phone,
or their mobile phone as their
preferred method of access.
We live in a market which
is one of the biggest
markets worldwide in
terms of app installs.
Our users aren't just
idly, casually browsing.
They're using the phone
to engage and to transact
in huge numbers.
Just look recently, for
one example, Singles' Day.
Again, this year, huge
growth, an astonishing event
on a global scale.
83% of all the transactions
on Singles' Day
were via the mobile phone.
If you were compare that
to Black Friday or Cyber
Monday in the US, the
corresponding number is 35%.
Why is this important?
You know this already.
It's important because
when you think about it,
you are developing in one
of the most advanced markets
in the world with some of
the most advanced consumers
in the world.
And so you are
ready to go global.
When you look at app
usage around the world,
app usage is doubling
year on year.
Users are spending about
an hour a day in apps,
and when you combine
that with high growth
that we see in markets such as
Indonesia or Brazil or India
or Vietnam, there is huge
opportunity for all of you
to take your ideas beyond China.
And we're going to explore some
of the products, the tools,
the services that you can
use from Google to help
you do that today.
We're going to talk about
things like Sand Hill.
Sand Hill is a
project within Google
where we connect with the
venture capital community
and we explore with
them their investments
and think about which
of the developers
they're working with could
benefit from Google's tools,
the goal being for
the entrepreneur
to go bigger, faster, cheaper,
so actually your equity
is worth an awful lot more.
We're going to have a panel
on that later on today.
I could talk to you
also about 5miles.
5miles is a developer
based here in Beijing,
actually co-located now
in the US, a great team.
They have a mobile
classifieds app.
But their browse
product wasn't as good,
and it was causing
a lot of leakage.
They couldn't convert people
from their first impression
of 5miles into the app.
And so we worked with
5miles and we created what
we call a progressive web app.
And it creates an app-like
experience in the browser.
The results were startling.
The bounce rates halved,
and the conversion rates
increased by over 60%.
Even outside of product,
we hope we can be useful.
I could talk to
your about MeToo.
MeToo is a photo editing app
that many of you no doubt use.
They were interested
in Indonesia
as one of those high
growth markets, very
mobile ready markets, but
they don't know anything
about Indonesia.
We were able to put them
in contact with our team
on the ground to give them a
little bit of insight in terms
of the operating environment,
the regulatory situation, how
users interacted with devices,
where to find those users, what
those users might cost.
And as a result
of that, they were
able to make a far more
educated decision in terms of
whether or not Indonesia
was right for them.
These examples and
more you're going
to hear throughout the keynote
and throughout the different
break outs during the day.
It's really a celebration
of your entrepreneurship.
Actually, I'm going to
give you one more example.
And actually, I'm going
to focus on gaming.
To be honest, I
have lots of choice.
Chinese app developers
lead the way,
whether it's more about
lifestyle apps, productivity
apps, entertainment apps.
But gaming, in particular,
is a very hot area.
We've seen 150% growth
in mobile gaming revenues
over the last two years,
and it is actually
an entertainment giant.
It's 2 and 1/2 times the
size of the movie business.
A lot of this, of course, is
built on the Android platform,
which is the most scaled
platform globally,
and actually within Android
as a way of reaching users,
you have Google Play, which
can reach consumers in over 190
markets worldwide.
ELEX knew that.
ELEX, the creators
of Clash or Kings,
built their app in China, for
China-- a multiplayer game,
fantastic fun.
But they can actually
see that actually they
can connect with consumers
all around the world.
And they've done so
to tremendous effect.
In fact, let's hear
from them directly.
Let's play the video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
[END PLAYBACK]
SCOTT BEAUMONT: Very good.
It's stories like these that
really inspire us and motivate
the teams within Google.
So it's-- hopefully
you can still see me.
And there are many
more examples.
And you saw some of the
products and services
that we brought
to bear for ELEX.
You're going to hear
from Ben and Naomi
about still more of
those as we go forward.
Before I hand over, let
me just reflect again,
thank you all for coming,
welcome you here, and also
remind you the GDD
events, the developer
events we run both here
in Beijing and Shanghai,
or the events we run
in China generally
are the largest
such events that we
run the whole of Asia-pacific.
As a consequence of that,
you've got a lot of Googlers
in the room.
You've got Googlers in the
room from our local offices
here in Shanghai and Beijing,
you have team members
from around Asia, and you've
got a lot of our product team
also, across from the US.
Please take advantage of it.
Speak to us.
What do you need?
What's the killer feature
that you are missing?
What is the product
that you'd like to see?
What does the niggle that
you have in the everyday
that you would like
to see corrected?
Talk to us.
Help us make us better in
order to serve you better.
We want to bring
your ideas to life
and we want to
help you go global.
Very good.
Shall we get started?
Let me handover to Ben to
begin our product journey.
[CHINESE]
SPEAKER 1: [SPEAKING CHINESE].
Please welcome to
the stage Director
and Product Management, Google
Developer Group, Ben Galbraith.
BEN GALBRAITH: Pleasure to be
here with you this morning.
[CHINESE] Ben.
That's all the Chinese I
can manage this morning.
It's a pleasure to be with you.
I've had the opportunity
to visit China three
times this year.
And I have loved coming here.
In fact, recently
this past summer,
I was able to bring my
wife and our eight children
to travel throughout East Asia.
Thank you.
My family would spend their
days learning mandarin
in immersion school while
I met with developers.
And then in the evenings
we'd get together
and experience the
wonders of China
and other countries
in the region.
It's well known that
the Chinese developer
community is world class in
your talent and your skill.
But I've been particularly
impressed in the time
that I've spent here with the
warmth and the friendliness
of the people that I've met.
It's truly a pleasure for me to
be able to spend time with you.
And I wish that those of
you on the live stream
could be here with me as well.
We're on a mission at Google
to make developers successful,
to help them succeed
at what they're doing.
And we've been investing
in helping developers here
in China.
For example, back in May we
partnered with Youku and LeTV
to stream our Google I/O
Keynote here in China.
And over 1 million
of you tuned in
to hear our latest
announcements.
I was thrilled with the
participation that we saw.
We also have many local
events and training programs
happening on the ground here.
You can stay connected to all of
this through our WeChat account
called Google Developers.
We've really enjoyed having
this channel to stay connected
with the developer community.
Our teams have absolutely
loved using it.
Please, follow along with us.
I think we have a QR code for
it that we'll show in a moment.
So you can follow
right now on WeChat.
I'm also pleased to announce
this morning that we've just
launched three developer
sites on China domains,
each with content in
simplified Chinese.
And we've created a section that
showcases the technologies that
are most relevant to
local Chinese developers,
and that showcase our
local developer programs.
And we're also
announcing this morning
that we're bringing our Google
Developer agency program here
to China, which
offers certifications
to those agencies that are
building the highest quality
apps.
And I think it's going to be
a great way for us to connect
top quality development shops
with businesses that are
looking for a trusted partner.
This is just a
sampling of what we're
doing to support Chinese
businesses and developers.
Now I want to shift gears
and talk to you about some
of the technologies that
we've been working on.
I want to start with the web.
So for the past
year or so, we've
been focused on making the
web fantastic on mobile.
This is about expanding
the web's capabilities
and it's also about making
the web really fast.
Now, we've done a ton
of work in this area,
including enhancing our
own Chrome web browser,
working with web
standards bodies,
and launching many, many new
products to help developers.
This morning, I want to focus
on two of these initiatives
that we've launched to
help web developers.
First, we've worked together
with the web community
to develop and promote something
that we call Progressive Web
Apps, or PWAs, for short.
[AUDIO OUT]
In addition to
service workers, PWAs
include many other
notable, new capabilities.
I'm going to go
through a few of them.
One, it gives you native-like
background notifications,
and these work even when
the browser is closed,
which brings that up to
par with native apps.
PWAs also give your
users a new, easy way
to add an icon shortcut
to your web experience
to their launcher, just
like with native apps,
and it's one of the things that
helps users keep coming back
to these PWA experiences.
They also offer a new
sign in experience
that enables web sessions
to persist much longer
than before, similar
to with native apps,
so users don't have to log in
as often into your experience.
And they integrate with
the new web payments
API, which gives us
a powerful new way
to make buying things through
a web browser really friction
free and really easy.
In addition to these benefits,
PWAs use HDTPS all the time
for enhanced security.
And if you do it
right, they can have
buttery smooth, 60
frames per second updates
to your user interface, which
makes them really, really
fun to use.
And they can resize
gracefully to displays
of all shapes and sizes.
PWAs are truly the next
generation of the web.
Developers who have made PWAs
are seeing great results.
Scott just told you about 5miles
which is a great case study.
I want to talk to
you about Alibaba.
We're all familiar with
Alibaba's incredible success
worldwide in over 200 countries.
They're one of many world
class Chinese innovators.
They recently
built a PWA, and it
led to a 76% increase
in conversion
for their web users, which
is a fantastic improvement.
And because they
implemented features
like Add to Homescreen, and use
the push notifications that I
described, they've brought
their re-engagement
a measure of how often
users keep coming back
to that experience on the
web up to the same level
as it was for their native app.
All right, so that's PWAs.
The second initiative
I want to talk to you
about is called
Accelerated Mobile Pages.
We just call it AMP for short.
And while PWA was
about expanding
the capabilities
of web browsers,
AMP is really more
about streamlining
what we do with
the web to deliver
a trimmed down, open source web
format that loads instantly.
It works by defining
a subset of HTML
and using web
components to create
a set of HTML that loads
without blocking on any network
resources.
So it shows up instantly, and
the images and JavaScript load
asynchronously, and you're
guaranteed when you use AMP
that none of these
resources, as they load,
will cause the web page
to have to repaint itself.
We call it a reflow when it
has to lay itself out again
because something
that's loaded has
caused it to change its layout.
As a result, these things
create just a really fast, fast,
fast experience
that pulls users in.
We found that over
700,000 domains are now
serving at least
AMPed page, and it's
compatible with more than 70 eds
and analytic solutions, which
are important as you
monetize and measure
what's happening on your site.
Many popular web platforms like
WordPress, Drupal, Squarespace,
and Shopify, have integrated
AMP into their platforms, which
makes it super easy for
you to take your content
and make it AMP compatible.
And these are just web pages,
so anyone can host them.
But we've created something
called the Google AMP
Cache, which is a
free, global caching
service for all AMP content.
Anyone can use this
thing, and it's
another one of the ingredients
that makes AMP really fast,
because when they're
hosted with this cache,
pages load even faster than if
users pull them from the origin
servers.
We're seeing a lot of industry
adoption of AMP pages,
with sites like Bing,
Twitter, Pinterest,
and of course our own Google
Search linking to AMP pages
and using the AMP
cash when available.
We're also continuing
to evolve AMP.
We're working with e-commerce
companies such as eBay
to take what we've done and
to expand its capabilities
to work even better in
domains like e-commerce.
And one of my
favorite sayings is
that we've integrated
AMP and PWAs together
which, when you think
about it, is a pretty
compelling combination.
Because with AMP we can serve
a page instantly to users,
super fast, and then while
users are browsing that content,
we can load a PWA
in the background
and users can then convert
from the end page to the PWA
and have a rich,
interactive experience.
It's a great way to
keep your users engaged.
All right, so that's what
we're doing with the web.
I want to talk to you a
little bit about Android
for a few minutes.
It's really hard for me to wrap
my head around the sheer scale
of Android, whether
we're talking
about the users that
are engaged with it,
the number of devices
in the ecosystem,
or just its sheer
global presence.
As Scott mentioned, it's the
most popular mobile operating
system in the world, with
over 1.4 billion people
engaging with it.
And we're hard at work
at making Android better.
And in August of
this year, we just
rolled out to consumers the
latest version of Android
called NuGet, in
a gradual rollout.
I want to highlight
some of the new features
that this release brings
with it, because it's
got a lot of great stuff for
both consumers and developers.
These features include
multi windows support,
which is a feature
that enables users
to run two apps on the screen at
the same time in a split screen
mode.
It also gives enhanced
notifications.
And by this, I mean
we now support actions
in a standard way within
the notifications,
it's easier than ever for
developers to change the look
and feel of these notifications,
and related notifications are
bundled together with NuGet.
I also want to talk to you
about enhanced DOS mode.
So in Marshmallow, we introduced
something called DOS mode,
which is a low power state.
When the device's
screen is off and it's
laying flat on a table, we
enter this special DOS mode
that saves battery.
And with NuGet get we're
extending it further,
so that when the screen is off
but the device is in motion,
like in your pocket, we
trigger this low battery state.
And finally, NuGet
includes Vulkan,
which is a new,
industry standard,
low level graphics API that
delivers advanced performance
on the latest hardware.
NuGet also introduces
another major feature
I want to tell you about-- VR.
So we've been playing
with VR for a while.
Two years ago we launched
Google Cardboard,
and it's done a fantastic
job at giving people
a taste of what VR can be like
through short form experiences
that work on iOS and Android.
And frankly, the adoption
and success of Cardboard
has surpassed our expectations.
So with NuGet, we're
introducing a new platform
that we call
Daydream, that takes
our vision of
affordable, ubiquitous VR
to the next level.
Daydream is comprised
of three key elements.
It introduces a standard
for new Android handsets
that ensures that they can
deliver immersive, high quality
VR experiences.
It also includes a reference
design for a high quality VR
headset that's powered
by a Daydream handset,
and it includes a
reference design
for-- we call it
positionally aware controller
that knows where it
is, and that users
can use to engage in these
immersive virtual environments.
We launched the first
Daydream compatible device,
the Pixel Phone by Google,
earlier this year in the fall.
And we also launched
our own Daydream headset
and controller.
More devices are coming in early
2017 from partners like Waway,
and you can start developing
for Daydream today.
We've also partnered
with younity
to make it easy for you
to create new, immersive,
virtual worlds for
people to engage with,
and developers like NetEase
are already creating
apps for the Daydream platform.
Out on the floor, we've
got a few Daydream headsets
out there.
And I encourage you to go
out and engage with these
and play with them.
I think you'll find
they're really cool.
All right, so the best way to
actually develop for Android
is with Android Studio,
our official Android IDE.
You can download it today
from the Android developer
site on the China domain
that we just launched.
We recently updated Android
Studio to Version 2.2,
and we focus these updates
around three major themes,
speed, smarts, and
Android platform support.
I'll just summarize
these briefly.
For speed, you can
develop faster,
with a new feature
that we're introducing
called the New Layout Designer.
Now, for ages, we've been
hand-coding our layouts
on Android, and this
designer makes it really,
really easy to create
complex layouts that
resize to all sorts of
different screen sizes,
and adapt to
orientation changes.
And it does it with a new,
intuitive layout design
interface.
It is really, really nice,
and you should check it out.
In terms of smarter,
Android Studio 2.2
includes out new ABK analyzer,
an enhanced layout inspector,
expanded code analysis, the
latest IntelliJ features,
and much more.
And finally, as the official
IDE for the Android platform,
Android Studio 2.2
includes support
for all the latest developer
features in Android NuGet,
like code completion to help
you implement multi windows
support, or the
redesign notifications
that I talked to you about
in just a moment ago.
And it includes
faster than ever,
built-in Android emulators for
you to test all this stuff out.
Once you've made
a fantastic app,
Google Play is the best way
to make your app available
globally.
Google Play had more
than 65 billion apps
installed just last year.
It's creating a phenomenal
market for Android developers
to build globally
successful businesses,
and as Scott mentioned
earlier, Chinese developers
are seeing great success
introducing their apps
to the global marketplace
through Google Play.
With these updates to the web
and to the Android platform,
we're increasing the
capabilities of what
you can do on mobile devices.
I now want to talk to you a
little bit about what we're
doing to make it easier for
you to develop experiences
on top of these platforms.
To do that, I'd like to
introduce a colleague of mine,
Naomi Black, to talk to you
about an open source project
that we've developed
at Google called
Angular that's received a lot
of traction here in China.
With that, I'll turn
it over to Naomi.
Thank you.
SPEAKER 1: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
Please welcome to the stage,
lead for Angular, Naomi Black.
NAOMI BLACK: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
I'm sorry.
I'm missing some of my notes.
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
Hi.
I'm Naomi.
I'm one of the leads on Google's
open source Angular project.
Back in 2009, when client side
development was still new,
we created Angular
to help developers.
Our goal was a
framework that could
make web development easier.
Since then we've seen
tremendous growth with Angular,
with millions of developers
around the world,
and thousands and thousands of
apps built with the framework.
In China, we know
Angular is well-loved.
Visitors from China are
the second largest segment
of our developer population.
Because of the enthusiasm of
the developer community here,
and thanks to our dedicated
team of Chinese contributors,
this year we launched
Angular's first localized site,
angular.sn, where you
can find Chinese versions
of all our developer guides and
our growing WeChat community.
We also have a Chinese
language talk this afternoon
on local adoption from our
China developer PM, [CHINESE],
with some of our partners, Hi-R
group, ZTEsoft, and [CHINESE],
presenting their
experience in Angular.
To the many Angular
developers here today,
I want to say thank you.
It is so exciting
to be here in China,
and we are here because of you.
To those of you here who
don't know Angular yet,
let me introduce the framework,
our history, and some
of the problems we're solving.
We started Angular seven
years ago as a framework
to make client side
developers more productive.
Our team gained
years of experience
in knowing what it takes to
build and support a front end
framework and make it
fast and performant.
The web has changed tremendously
since Angular began.
This September we
released a new Angular,
rebuilt for modern
cross-platform development.
Today I'm going to
cover what is included
in Angular for
developing applications,
for mobile, desktop and web.
So first, let me
talk about how we've
made Angular more modular by
better defining and Angular's
core.
The core API has
provided a foundation
that you need to build all apps.
Angular's core APIs include
declarative templating that
allows you to use standard
HTML and Angular markup
to create powerful
UIs, automatic change
detection, dependency
injection improved
from our pioneering
implementation in Angular 1,
an intuitive component model
that allows you to structure
your apps with
reusable architecture
and natural separation
of concerns,
and our new compiler, which
is capable of static analysis,
giving you not only small
and fast apps, but also
improved error messaging
and automatic refactoring,
the ability to swap
renderers, so you get true Dom
independence, and you can target
platforms where no Dom exists.
And this is really
critical for mobile.
Beyond these foundational
building blocks.
There are many
more things that we
know most applications
will need,
for example, UI components.
We knew that we could make
developers more productive
by providing APIs
for these use cases.
But we also wanted to
keep Angular flexible.
So you can choose,
as developers,
use our implementation,
you can write your own,
or you can find
one of the options
out there in our
growing ecosystem.
So among the additions
we have in Angular,
we now have Angular
material, which
is a tool of beautiful
design UI components
so you can go from ZeroApp
to Beautiful App really fast.
We have IET and PIs for your
internationalization needs.
We brought a
powerful forms module
for quickly developing user
input forms with validation.
We have animations so that
your apps look and respond
with style, and users
will enjoy using them.
And last, we have
ngUpgrade, which
allows you to mix and match
old and new Angular components
in the same application.
So if you're one of the millions
of Angular 1 developers,
you can migrate
at your own pace.
So I've talked about the
building blocks of Angular.
What about all the other places
that you need your apps to run?
First, Angular is great
for progressive web apps.
We have a full talk from
developer advocate Stephen
Fluin on this in the mobile
web track later today.
And for many consumer
apps, an app store presence
is essential.
So we've partnered with
Ionic and with Onsen UI, two
solutions that let you use
all of the goodness of web
technologies, but
then package that up
for the app store presence.
If you prefer Native,
Telerik's NativeScript
works by swapping out our
renderer for one that can
render to a native mobile OS.
And this is possible
because of Angular's Dom
independent renderer.
Finally, for the desktop,
with GitHub's electron,
you can build in Angular
and take advantage
of all the machine resources.
If you've used VS code,
that's an electron app.
So as with native mobile,
there are more places
where there is no Dom.
And we wanted Angular
to run there to you.
So Angular now includes
server side rendering,
so that the server can
render our component's view.
This currently works in
Node and asp.net today,
and the new Angular can
deploy to many platforms.
So I've talked about the
building blocks of Angular
and where your apps can run.
But what about the tools
that you use as a developer?
You can write an Angular
application using
plain ES5 or ES6 JavaScript.
But we think that
most developers
will want to use TypeScript.
We like TypeScript
because it makes
it a lot easier
to write and think
about Angular applications.
We actually used TypeScript
to write Angular ourselves.
And I would love to tell you
the beautiful engineering
story that happened when
the love between our two
open source projects at
Microsoft and at Google
came together, but
I'm going to save that
for our TypeScript
in Angular talk
this afternoon, which
we are co-presenting
in Chinese and in English, with
Microsoft engineer [CHINESE],
from the TypeScript team.
So why did Angular adopt
TypeScript for our own code?
First, we could write
code and find beds faster.
The readability of
our code in TypeScript
was greatly improved.
And this was critical because
we had many engineers working
together in many different
parts of the framework,
and they needed to
quickly understand what
the other engineers had done.
They found they could
collaborate much more easily.
And we found that
we could easily
build much better
tooling, like Angular CLI.
So with Angular's command line
interface, you can type ngnew
and we'll create all
the scaffolding and all
the boilerplate
plate for you, so
that when finally these
commands finish running,
you can simply type ngsurf.
Then you move over
to your local browser
and your app will magically
be there, fully functional,
so that you can focus
on application logic,
not on the boilerplate plate.
The CLI is one way
that we're investing
in tooling, to make it easier
for you to write Angular code.
We also provide Protractor,
which enables full end
to end testing.
Angular and also works great
with your favorite IDE,
and will give you helpful error
messaging and refactoring tips.
Last, our partners at
Rangel.io have built
a tool called Angular Augury.
Augury gives you real time
insight into performance
and things like
routing in your app,
so you can debug and see
what's happening in your app
much faster.
This is just a taste of what
the new Angular can do today
for mobile, desktop,
and the web,
and how we improve
developer productivity.
We hope that you'll join us
in the sessions later today
to learn more, and look
for the Angular apps
on the app showcase
board on the third floor.
So now I'd like to
introduce my colleague
Ben to come back on stage.
[CHINESE]
BEN GALBRAITH: Thank you, Naomi.
That's fantastic.
So as excited as I am about
all the new developments
that we've shared you this
morning around the Android
and the web, you know, it's
still quite a lot of work
to create a high quality
mobile experience
on top of these platforms.
Part of that reason is
because user expectations
continue to raise
from what they want
to see from a high quality app.
We know this first hand,
because at Google, we've
created some of the world's
most popular mobile apps,
and we've learned a
lot in the process,
and we've built a
lot of infrastructure
to support those applications.
Some time ago, we
decided to take
some of the internal
infrastructure
that we'd built, along
with our experience,
and packaged it up
together in a way
that we could share
with other developers.
And we decided to go
beyond the web and Android,
and offer solutions to help
iOS developers as well, which
was natural for us because
we're iOS developers ourselves.
The result is something
that we call Firebase.
We shipped it earlier
this year at Google I/O.
It's a comprehensive set
of tools to make it easier
to create high quality mobile
apps on iOS, on Android,
or the web.
It has many features, such
as free and unlimited app
analytics, crash
reporting, asset
hosting with CDN integration
automatically provided.
It's also got a powerful
remote configuration
service that lets you adapt
what your application does
on the fly, and much more.
Each of these features is
designed to be used standalone.
You can take just what you want.
But we've also
designed these features
to work really well together.
For example, Firebase
Analytics, you
can define groups of
users called audiences
and then reuse these audiences
in Firebase remote config
to change the way your app
behaves for different groups.
Or you can send messages
to these different groups
of users, to these audiences,
using Firebase notifications.
One of my favorite integrations
is between Firebase Crash
Reporting and
Analytics, because when
your user's experience
a crash, heaven forbid,
you see a breadcrumb trail of
all the analytics events that
occurred leading up to that
crash right in the crash
reporting tool without the
need to do further analysis.
It's pretty cool.
Since we released this in
May, over 750,000 projects
have been created on
the Firebase platform.
And since launch, we've
shipped a steady stream
of improvements and new
features to our developers.
I can't wait for you to learn
more about Firebase today,
about how it can help
you build great apps,
grow your user base,
and earn more money.
Our vision here is to
free up more of your time
so that you can
spend it on creating
innovative new features
for your users,
and not reproduce infrastructure
that other people have already
created.
We've got a bunch
of sessions today
that go into depth
on these features,
and how Chinese developers,
such as YeeCall,
have used features like Firebase
Analytics and Remote Config
to power their own
global applications.
We're deeply committed
to this space,
and we look forward to
delivering many more
enhancements to Firebase
in the years to come.
Finally, before I go,
there's one last topic
I want to cover--
machine learning.
Machine Learning,
or ML for short,
is at the heart of many of
the magical software features
that we've shipped in
Google products recently.
It's also what enabled AlphaGo
to defeat Go Champion Lee
Sedol earlier this
year, which was
a tremendous technical
achievement, well beyond what
many thought was the state
of the art for our industry
by many, many years.
And I'm thrilled that we've made
the same ML framework that we
use internally at
Google available to you
through an open source
project called TensorFlow.
TensorFlow works by giving you
a way to define a data model,
and then use that model to
analyze large amounts of data.
And it's these large data sets
that enable your TensorFlow
model to identify patterns.
And these patterns lead to
these magic-like inferences
that can be identifying
people in a photo,
or extracting the meeting
from a body of text.
Our CEO, Sundar
Pichai, frequently
talks about how Google is now
becoming an AI-First company,
and it's technologies
like TensorFlow
that are behind this transition
and some of our latest products
and most exciting features.
I'm really pleased that
today at the event,
you'll have the opportunity
to attend sessions that go
into more detail on TensorFlow.
An example of one of
the products that we're
shipping that's powered
by machine learning
is the new Google Assistant, our
conversation oriented platform
that's embedded in several
of our consumer products,
like Google Home and Pixel.
Back in October, we
announced that we'd
be partnering with the
developer community
by creating an integration
platform for the Google
Assistant.
We call this Actions on Google.
And the first version
of this platform
is launching just a little
bit later this month.
We also acquired
recently, a company
called Api.ai, which
creates a web based platform
that makes it really
easy for you to create
compelling conversation
experiences that
work not just on the
Google Assistant,
but on many of the other
conversation platforms
that are emerging
in today's market.
Real, viable
conversational interfaces
are an exciting new
frontier for our industry,
and I'm super excited that
we can go on this journey
together.
Stay tuned to our WeChat
account for further developments
as this space evolves rapidly.
And we have Google Home
here in the Sandbox
that you can check out today.
All right, thank
you for joining us.
Today is our opportunity
to work together
to learn about all
these technologies.
We have over 35
breakout sessions
that go even deeper in all
the stuff that I've mentioned.
We've got a demo
area where you can
speak with many Googlers and
some of our developer partners
who have been creating
apps in the ecosystem.
And we have a special
app showcase area.
This is a tradition
for our GDD events,
where we've highlighted
50 apps that
showcase the amazing innovations
that Chinese developers are
bringing to the global market.
I speak for all of
us here at Google
when I tell you we are
so excited to be here,
and to be working with you.
And we want to partner
with you to help
you achieve success as
you create great apps
and build global businesses.
[CHINESE]
SPEAKER 1: [SPEAKING CHINESE].
Thank you for joining us.
Breakout sessions
will begin shortly.
Please see your badge for
room locations and schedule.